you and I remember Budapest very
differently what are you doing
she's disabling security protocols and
dumping all the secrets under the
internet including hydrants and shields
if you do this none of your past is
gonna remain hidden that Budapest not
Osaka
after children's war are you sure you're
ready for the world to see you as you
really are
hey everybody is Charlie we have awesome
news we have an official synopsis for
the Black Widow movie during phase four
so we got to break it down there's a new
round of that spider-man ps4 giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the official synopsis reads at
birth the Black Widow aka Natasha
Romanoff is given to the KGB which
grooms her to become the ultimate
operative when the USSR breaks up the
government tries to kill her as the
action moves to present-day New York
where she's a freelance operative the
standalone film will find Romanov living
in the United States 15 years after the
fall of the Soviet Union so timeline
explainer that means that it's around
2006 somewhere in the mid 2000s when she
was in her early 20s MCU black widow was
born around 1984 making her about 34
years old as of the events of infinity
war she's not that old she's not quite
as old as comic-book Black Widow gonna
be pretty easy for Scarlett Johansson to
play a 20 year old version of herself
because she's not that old in real life
anyway she's not gonna need any of that
special Nick Fury Botox that Sam Jackson
was joking about but if you've ever
wondered about the fall of the Soviet
Union in the early 90s and her age and
present-day and why it doesn't match up
you just remember that she was given to
the KGB and sent to the Red Room at
birth if the official fall of the Soviet
Union was December 1991 she would have
been about 7 years old as the
description says when the government
tried to start killing her just to get
rid of all its dirty secrets so that's
what she would have fled to the United
States and eventually within a couple
years that become a freelance operative
just going on on jobs as a mercenary it
gets a little weird if you look at those
age of Ultron deleted scenes in the
flashbacks that she has to the Red Room
because obviously
the big thing that happened to her is
that they removed her ovaries they had
that whole big conversation during age
of Ultron about their relationship and
how she'd never be able to have children
because of what they did to her I can't
have this kids do the math I physically
can't neither can I
[Music]
in the Red Room where I was trained
where I was raised
they have a graduation ceremony they
sterilize you
it's efficient
[Music]
one less thing to worry about the one
thing that might matter more than a
mission makes everything easier even
killing
[Music]
you still think you're the only monster
on the team so I wouldn't worry about
that too much because it sounds like
they'll just have flashbacks to her
training in the Red Room then obviously
the fall her running to the United
States and then there'd be like a time
jump to 15 years later when she's in her
early 20s so with most of the movie
takes place around 2006 it's actually
pretty easy to involve Hawkeye and
Winter Soldier Winter Soldier was still
be working for Hydra so if she runs into
him it would be on a job where he's
working for Hydra and she's working for
someone else so I know I put those clips
about Budapest at the beginning of this
he could be involved in a Budapest like
incident where they see him from the
other side but the way she talks about
him during Winter Soldier is his only in
legend like she's heard things about
someone called the Winter Soldier but
she doesn't know who Bucky Barnes is so
she wouldn't recognize him most of the
intelligence community doesn't believe
he exists the ones that do you call him
the Winter Soldier he's credited with
over two dozen assassinations in the
last 50 years so he's a ghost story five
years ago I was escorting a nuclear
engineer out of Iran somebody shot out
my tires near Odessa we lost control
went straight over a cliff I pulled us
out but the Winter Soldier was there I
was covering my engineer so he shot him
straight through me
Soviets luck now rightfully genious so
if they decide to include him it'd be
interesting to see how they would
interact with each other because it's
not like later he would remember that
it'll be a little weird even though as
of infinity war Sheree fixed winter
soldiers brain and deprogrammed all the
Hydra stuff out most of his memories
from the past are from stuff with
Captain America from way way back during
World War two hopefully they'll find
some way to make it work it's a lot
easier to include Hawkeye because then
everybody's wondering what's gonna
happen with him and phase four
so another timeline explainer for
Hawkeye is relationship with Nick Fury
predating the Black Widow so if the
movie takes place around 2006 that's
still a couple years away from the
Avengers or from the events of Iron Man
2 you have to imagine that she's working
by herself Nick Fury might know who she
is and be tracking her but if the
Budapest incident took place before Iron
Man 2 and that was during 2010 you have
to imagine that Nick Fury is evaluating
Black Widow for potential recruitment
just watching her monitoring her using
Hawkeye because Hawkeye had been working
for Nick Fury for a couple years by the
time Black Widow landed on his radar so
I wouldn't be surprised if they want to
include Hawkeye if he runs into her
while she's on a freelance hit they help
each other out he helps bring her into
shield and maybe we get Budapest now
that doesn't mean that they're
guaranteed to do it nowhere in the plot
does it say they go on a mission
together or Hawkeye or Winter Soldier is
going to be involved but of all the
Avengers characters that were around at
that time operating as either vigilantes
or as members of Hydra is just easiest
to include them and even within the
comics she has a much deeper longer
relationship with those characters you
don't necessarily need a whole lot of
Nick Fury to accomplish all that stuff
but a cameo at least would be really
nice if he shows up at the end of the
movie and gives her that speech that he
gave at the end of the first Iron Man
movie to Tony Stark you're part of a
larger world and then he tells her about
somebody named Tony Stark that he wants
her to go keep an eye on then she just
rolls her eyes into the back of her head
like aw geez Tony Stark and you get the
events of Iron Man 2 but like during
that Winter Soldier clip that I put at
the beginning of this Alexander Pierce
calls out Osaka like she did something
really bad and Osaka probably killed a
whole bunch of really important people I
also
love the way that he mentioned
Children's Ward implying suddenly that
she killed a whole bunch of children or
did something really terrible in a
children's ward
so any number of the events that
Alexander Pierce rattled off could be
done during the plot of the Black Widow
movie let me know in the comments though
how do you want them to invoke the other
Marvel characters that were around at
that time like Hawkeye or Winter Soldier
another really cool thing in related
news Tom Holland was spotted in a brand
new spider-man suit on the set of
spider-man homecoming so I'll do a video
for that tomorrow but leave all your
requests in the comments below
speaking of which Black Widow has
crossed over with spider-man several
times in the comics they've teamed up
but you have to imagine that that's an
older version of Peter Parker they even
had a relationship for a brief period I
haven't heard anything about her showing
up on the set of far from home but it
sounds like they've been prepping the
Black Widow movie so it might just be a
schedule thing preventing her from cameo
in that movie I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post that click here for
that Avengers 4 title teaser and click
here for that brand new venom trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you